nachwuchs auf der beide ganz ohne
menschliche hilfe hat die königin so
heißt diese mutterkuh vor ein paar
minuten ihr stil kälbchen könig laurin
zur welt gebracht
auf dem heiderhof im voralpenland
liefern 35 kühe biochemisch in der
mieter qualität bauer albert stürzer hat
die mutter und ihr jetzt vier stunden
altes kalb inzwischen von der weide in
den up calbe stall gebracht
[Musik]
ja wir haben ja denn da im stall kann
der landwirt sicherstellen dass der
kleine bulle genug biestmilch bekommt es
ist die erste milch und diese die
wichtigsten wertvollste gorbi weil du
heute die ganzen schutzstoffe drin sein
weil ja kolb hat ja nach der geburt
können ereignis immunsystem und das gibt
es praktisch über die piste nicht
verabreicht davor es hoffentlich bei die
selber kapital und winkt ein bisserl
noch aber er wird schon noch die zitzen
der kleine könig laurin wird die
nächsten vier wochen hier bei seiner
mutter bleiben
mutterkuh gebundene kälber haltung heißt
das in der fachsprache die kroatin
schulstunde lang richtig sie massiert
und objekt und das gestärkte sofort das
immunsystem sind die kälber jetzt
gesünder wenn die bei der mutter bleiben
sind die väter können die sachen besser
was ich mag das ja jetzt komme
eigentlich tief in die tiefe stehen was
ich hier erlebe ist gut fürs kalt aber
die ausnahme
der alltag in deutschen ställen sieht
ganz anders aus
über 4,2 millionen milchkühe gibt es in
deutschland doch nur 15 prozent werden
als sogenannte mutterkühe gehalten die
ihre kälber selbst zeugen bei allen
anderen werden die kälber gleich nach
der geburt von ihren müttern getrennt
damit sie uns nicht die milch weg
trinken
zwischen 21 und 37 15
das ist unser haupt landwirt albert
stürzer kann sich die mutterkuhhaltung
nur leisten weil er für seine bio ei
milch einen sehr anständigen milchpreis
bekommt 60 cent pro liter
um überhaupt milch geben zu können muss
eine kuh regelmäßigkeiten albert stürzer
hält fleckvieh ein sogenanntes zwei
nutzungs rente die kühe geben ordentlich
milch die stiere eignen sich für die
mast
doch die mehrheit unserer milchkühe sind
schwarzbunte holstein frisia eine reine
milch rasse hochleistungskühe die extrem
viel milch liefern dafür aber kaum
fleisch auf die rippen bekommen
[Musik]
ich besuche den hof von rolf trede der
landwirt hält 140 milchkühe ihre milch
geht an eine örtliche molkerei die
milchpulver an die lebensmittelindustrie
liefern
damit konkurriert der bauer mit dem
weltmarkt entsprechend niedrig ist sein
milchpreis 28 cent pro liter bio bauer
stürzer bekommt mehr als das doppelte
trotzdem dürfen auch rediske vom
melkstand direkt auf die weide
kostendruck ist der ständige begleiter
von milchbauer rolf trede auf seinem hof
werden die kälber gleich nach der geburt
von den müttern getrennt und separat
gehalten
nach der immunstärkende biestmilch
müssten kälber rein gesetzlich gar keine
milch ihrer mutterkuh mehr bekommen
beiträge gibt es immerhin pulver aus
vollmilch dass diese auf die ernährung
form von kalb abgestimmtes mit
mineralien und vitaminen hat gesagt und
fettgehalt ist nicht das was aus der
chor aus kommt genau auf skalp
abgestimmt ich meine beiträge dürfen die
kälber so viel trinken wie sie wollen
branchenüblich sind zwei mal vier liter
am tag aus dem mülleimer
weil die schwarz punkten kälber so
schlecht fleisch ansetzen ist ihre
fütterung ein ständiges ringen um
effizienz bis jetzt zur einzügigkeit
also also ein reines mich nicht kalt was
würden sie denn für die jetzt kriegen
wenn sie die verkaufen
ich würde über die glück habt zu den
oberen zehn euro
auftrittes hof kommen 140 kelber im jahr
zur welt um die milchproduktion am
laufen zu halten
für seine milchkuh nachzucht benötigt er
aber nur 40 weibliche tiere
den rest muss er irgendwie verkaufen der
bauer müht sich seine kälber stehen auf
strom obwohl das gesetzlich nur in den
ersten zwei wochen sein muss er lässt
einige kühe von fleisch rindern
befruchten um marktfähige hre kälber zu
bekommen
er verwendet so genanntes gesetztes
schwärmer um beim nachwuchs gezielt nur
weibliche tiere für die milchwirtschaft
zu erzeugen alles kostenfaktoren wenn
ich das jetzt mal hochrechnen sind im
jahr über 100 keller übrig
diese halt irgendwie in den markt für
die sie aber eigentlich nicht so viel
geld kriegen dass es sich lohnt ohne
kälber keine milch aber wohin führt es
wenn in der landwirtschaft zwangsläufig
tiere erzeugt werden die nichts wert
sind
bei meinen recherchen bekomme ich immer
wieder hinweise auf sogenannte wegwerf
kälber besonders männliche tiere würden
oft direkt getötet sozusagen als
nutzloses nebenprodukt der milch kann
das sein
laut tierschutzgesetz wäre das töten der
tiere klar verboten
im mittel burg vorpommerschen grebin
nimmt tierschützer mike kinder in seinem
kälber hort seit 20 jahren kälber auf
die keiner will
weil sie etwa kleinwüchsig sind oder
krank auf seiner weide dürfen sie
friedlich weiter leben
beim abholen erlebt er den alltag auf
vielen milch müssen wenn sie da fünf
acht oder zehn euro vielleicht noch 56
kall kriegen dann bleibt ihnen gar
nichts anderes geprägt eine sehr gute
kaufmänner sein wollen und überleben
wollen sich von diesen tieren zu trennen
und was hat es von den tieren trennen
sie halt nicht versorgen oder
ja also das habe ich tatsächlich auch
schon auch selber gesehen dass die räder
nicht behandelt werden und denn so
einschlafen
es gibt ja auch so problemfälle von
calvin die dänin schlug also die nicht
saugen wollen und sowas und da stellt
sich keiner himmel macht sich die mühe
und ohne stiel victor war vor sechs
jahren so ein problem zu früh geboren
und dann in die gülle reingerutscht
zwei junge mädchen die gerade auf seinem
film drei waren auf diesem bauernhof von
deshalb beobachtet und haben dann sofort
den bauern oder mehl und das kälbchen
davon diesem von dieser kette runter
und er gezogen war wollten sie haben als
ein junges ich will herausfinden wie
viele kälber sterben und ob auffällig
viele bullen darunter sind doch jedes
bundesland zählt anders eindeutige
zahlen zur kälber sterblichkeit gibt es
nicht aber die meisten quellen kommen
auf zehn bis zwanzig tote kälber bei der
geburt und in den ersten lebenstagen an
der akademie für tierschutz des
deutschen tierschutzbundes in neubiberg
treffe ich die veterinär in frieda wird
sie recherchiert schon lange zu diesem
thema
ich will jetzt nicht die bauern per se
hier verdammt vielen betrieben kümmern
sich die leute um die kranken kälber
obwohl sie da nichts dran verdienen
obwohl sie draufzahlen
aber es ist eben nicht überall der fall
und es gibt auf einen betrieb meistens
fürchterlich viele sachen die gerade zu
tun sind und das kalb was eh nichts wert
ist ja fällt dann hinten runter bei den
bei den legehennen ist es ja vor allem
ein problem mit den männlichen küken ist
es bei den kälbern ähnlich es geht nicht
allein um die männlichen tiere es geht
auch um die weiblichen tiere die nicht
für die nachzucht also nicht wieder für
die milchproduktion in den nächsten
generationen genutzt werden die noch
zierlichen weiblichen körper die ja die
sind schwer zu meistern und wie gesagt
die werden gerade für fünf euro
verhökert also der bauer muss froh sein
wenn der silos wird für die neat
gewinnung erzeugen wir millionen tiere
die für die bauern nichts als eine last
system gewollte verschwendung von leben
ich möchte noch mal nachschauen wie sich
das neu geborene kalb entwickelt hat
morgens nach dem melken darf der kleine
könig laurin noch immer bei seiner
mutter trinken
in den ersten lebenswochen sind die
kälber auch hier nicht auf der weide aus
hygienegründen
die älteren kälber dürfen haus
[Musik]
alex ist drei monate alt und frisch von
der mutter entfernt
zur umstellung gibt es noch etwas
muttermilch aus dem lucke laimer doch
satt frisst sie sich jetzt auf der wiese
die leute wundern sich da auftut ist
jetzt einfach tut ja da ist jetzt die
die aufzucht kosten also bei bf 200 euro
sagt und bewusster vielleicht aus
politik
dies ist natürlich nur fleisch relativ
teuer
albert stürzer lässt seine bullenkälber
deshalb zu ausgewachsenen ochsen meisten
bei zwei nutzungs rindern lohnt sich das
denn egal ob bio oder konventionell bei
kalbfleisch ist das verhältnis zwischen
futterkosten und fleisch ausbeute
besonders ungünstig kalbfleisch stammt
fast immer von den nachkommen der
schwarzbunten hochleistungskühe die kein
ochsen mester haben will
wie funktioniert die mast von tieren die
sich für die mast im grunde gar nicht
eignen
ich besuche den betrieb von robert
wellen im emsland
über 1000 stellplätzen genaueres zum ort
dürfen wir nicht sagen
der mäster befürchtet ungebetenen besuch
von tierschützern aus hygienegründen
brauchen wir schutzkleidung
stoll 3 beherbergt 180 kälber die
gestern angekommen sind im schnitt 20
tage alt jeweils zu dritt bekommen sie
eine sechs quadratmeter box die werden
sie nicht mehr verlassen bis zur
schlachtung
alle kälber kriegen vom anfang vom
ersten bis zum letzten tag zweimal am
tag morgens um 6 uhr und abends um 17
uhr und ist das richtigem kurs oder was
für nein es ist keine richtige komik
richtige kuhmilch können wir nicht
vertreten
wie geht eine lebensmittelindustrie wir
machen uns einen eigenen
milchaustauscher ein ja das ist dasselbe
wie zb die babynahrung den setzen wir
zusammen aus stoffen die in der milch
drin sind ist klar müssen wir auch haben
wir bekommen ein pflanzenfett das
nachhaltig mit zertifikaten geliefert
wird bestehend aus kokos und palmöl
stadt münchen
nun ist milch schon so billig aber für
die kälber immer noch zu teuer
wo immer ich anhalte versuchen die tiere
sofort an meinen fingern zu saugen
hier gibt es keinen opel eimer mehr nur
eine tränke
mir fällt auf dass viele der kälber eine
ganz schön weite reise hinter sich haben
von bayern und baden württemberg ins
emsland sind es über 700 km
ist es denn schön für die kälber so oder
so nicht auf der weide nicht bei der
mutter dieses butter blümchen bild was
sie gerade sagten das können wir nicht
leisten dann werden wir in deutschland
nicht mehr satt und den kälbern den geht
es augenscheinlich gut hier die ist
augenscheinlich gut
teil eins ist der größte auf dem gelände
hier stehen 480 kälber kurz vor der
schlachtung sie sind knapp sieben monate
alt
ist das nicht ganz schön voll wie wir
eben gesehen haben wo reingekommen sind
kommt man sehen wohin gehen alle kälber
können legen 1,8 quadratmeter pro kalb
schreibt der gesetzgeber vor
zu fünft haben die tiere hier neun
quadratmeter fläche mit spalten boden
durch den treten die tiere selbst ihren
code in die güllegrube
das spart personal während ihrer ganzen
zeit im mastbetrieb wird hier nicht ein
einziges mal ausgemistet
[Musik]
das haben wir die tiere machen einen
gesunden eindruck
aber ist das hier wirklich ein
tiergerechtes leben um die nachkommen
unserer milchlieferanten schlachtreif zu
bekommen ist viel teures kraftfutter
nötig nur weil robert wellen die kälber
günstig einkaufen kann lohnt sich sein
geschäft dieses jahr zahlt er dennoch
drauf ein viertel des gesamten
kalbfleisch nimmt normalerweise die
gastronomie
es gibt jahre wo wir wirtschaftlich ganz
gut dastehen jetzt durch corona haben
wir natürlich ein riesen einbruch gehabt
und hoffen dass es nächstes jahr wieder
besser wird wenn die kunden bereit
werden viel mehr geld zu bezahlen was
würden sie anders machen in ihrem
betrieb wenn sie mir sagen was auf robe
für ein viertel der tiere christ du
genauso viel erlöst wie jetzt für die
gesamte dann will ich auch einfinden um
stellen hätte ich ja viel weniger arbeit
mehr platz mehr platz also was er beide
für das kalb ist dies aus unserer sicht
eine der besten haltungsform und es muss
auch machbar bleiben die beste
haltungsform oder die die am besten zum
extremen kostendruck passt auf eine
milchhof oberhalb des bayerischen
brandenburgs treffe ich die veterinäre
eva zeiler professorin an der uni wien
stef
neben ihrer forschungstätigkeit berät
sie milchbäuerinnen und milchbauern bei
der kälberaufzucht sie hält die
fütterung für das hauptproblem in dem
moment wo der ex meister ist würde der
ja keine vollmilch mehr kriegen sondern
wie ich aus münchen und das ist dieses
problem muss sagen dass er
schwierigkeiten kriegen unter umständen
für morgen ich höre zum teil ist das ja
auch mit palmöl oder irgendein
pflanzenführer eigentlich ja nicht das
was die normalerweise fressen würden ist
es dann tatsächlich genauso gut was echt
probleme machten diese pflanzliche
eiweiße und schon natürlich auch die
große menge an pflanzlichen fetten die
kälber hier auf dem hof bekommen
vollmilch direkt von der kuh aber auch
sie werden in einem mastbetrieb landen
dort droht ein weiteres problem und kaum
eine andere der sorte bekommt so viel
antibiotika wie mast kelber der mäster
kauft übertrieben gesagt 50 kraus 52
betrieben gekommene unterschiede keine
spektrums haben diese modelle die jungs
das immunsystem ist noch nicht fit die
haben den transport stress und das alles
sind stressfaktoren wo man einfach sagt
okay man möchte den denn den auswahl so
gering als möglich zu halten und geht in
die prophylaxe rein
das sagte kate die kommunen und creme
prophylaktisch ein antibiotikum damit
ziemlich krank werden gemäß dem letzten
monitoring der bundesregierung von 2016
bekommen kälber gleichbleibend große
mengen antibiotika während die menge bei
fast allen anderen tierarten sinkt in
sieben prozent der fleisch proben wurden
antibiotika rückstände gefunden teures
fleisch mit nebenwirkungen warum stellen
wir kälber und kühe nicht einfach auf
die weide
warum machen wir tiere fast zwangsläufig
zu patienten
ich schaue mir noch einmal die bilder
aus den maststall an die tiere dort
bekommen vor allem kraftfutter und
milchaustauscher auf der weide würden
gleichaltrige kälber ausschließlich gras
fressen und längst keine milch mehr
trinken
was bedeutet das für die tiere im bad
bramstedt besuche ich die
agrarwissenschaftlerin anne fabritz sie
berät kälber mester und hat die
fütterung und ihre folgen untersucht
heutzutage ist es nach wie vor so dass
viele irritiert sind wenn das kein
fleisch dunkler ist man assoziiert es
dann gleich mal mit ausgewachsenen
tieren dem ist aber nicht so im grunde
ist es eine krankheit liche veränderung
bei den kellern wir füttern sie bewusst
in einen eisenmangel zustand in einer
animieren auch und das ist ein zustand
der für skalp sicherlich nicht
gesundheitsfördernd ist also wenn das
fleisch so helles dann ist das kalb
eigentlich mangelernährt worden
ja helles fleisch vom milchkalb in
wahrheit kein qualitätsmerkmal sondern
das resultat von mangelernährung
fleisch von bio kälbern die tiergerecht
auf der weide grasen ist viel dunkler
tönen institut für ökologischen landbau
im schleswig holsteinischen westerau
first class den bart ihre studien zeigen
es tut kälbern gut wenn sie so gehalten
werden wie ist die natur vorsieht
ein argument was ich jetzt immer gehört
habe ist dass das hygienische gründe
auch hat also dass man diese kälber
sofort isolieren muss und alleine halten
damit die auf gar keinen fall irgendwie
krank werden wenn das für das kalb so
gefährlich für seiner mutter zu sein
werden ja kühe wahrscheinlich schon
längst ausgestorben
das ist natürlich so also von meiner
seite her wird es immer begrüßen dass
die frühzeitig zusammengehalten werden
weil das eben sind soziale tiere und wir
brauchen auch den sozialen kontakt
kerstin barth und ihre kollegen erproben
momentan bullenkälber von milch rassen
so naturnah wie möglich zu mästen
wir nehmen die männlichen kälber wir
messen sie nicht wie üblich im intensiv
mit mit milch oder mich austauschen und
kraftfutter sondern bestellen sie auf
die weide und das bedeutet natürlich
weniger zu namen heißt aber auch dass
sie eigentlich artgerechter ernährt
werden weil eben nicht die konzentration
auf die kraft futtermittel und die milch
erfolgt sondern eben kreis aufgenommen
wird und damit die ganz normale
entwicklung die in kalk durchmacht auch
durch gemacht werden kann
aber wo wir in den ökonomisch wissen wir
noch nicht
doch ist der zustand heute ökonomisch
gut tiere deren aufzucht sich kaum lohnt
und die trotzdem millionenfach geboren
werden weil es ohne sie keine milch gibt
ein system in dem es niemandem so
richtig gut geht wäre den tieren noch
den bauern
ich besuche ein letztes mal bowlen kalb
könig laurin er ist jetzt vier wochen
alt und wechselt von albert stürzer
milchhof zu einem mastbetrieb als kalt
wäre er in sechs monaten schlachtreif
der milchbauer ist froh dass sein kalb
noch gut zwei jahre als weide ochse vor
sich so sollten kälber immer aufwachsen
wir brauchen bessere gesetze für ein
system in dem tiere gut leben
bauern fair bezahlt werden und unser
fleisch uns nicht krank macht
[Musik]